welcome to this video playing a dread
head dread head from mmhmm yeah it's one
of those bala-tik States is dystonia yes
estonia yeah i don't know i will i'm not
i'm always unsure about those ok Knight
f3 here yeah one Bishop b5 that's bishop
d6 but here maybe I can just advance now
take it take it and just develop it's
probably not not bad yup c5 maybe it
should be six last night f5 so this
probably not good ok let's let's just
develop pieces CP probably will take now
and um after d takes I have a good
development with Bishop f5 and so on
looks looks ok ok it's not taking 16 at
least not instantly
yeah I don't really want to open it up
why not go to d6 okay so his point is to
play c5 yeah oh but at least I get some
d5 control should be shouldn't be
terrible
mmm what if i go Bishop f5 to see yeah
maybe he has he has some ideas too
exactly to push with g4 and these kind
of ideas okay well age five it's
probably he will play this g-force stuff
anyway
hmm how'd you get counterplay okay this
I probably need to do anyway and now
let's check yeah I can go see five try
to open up the center you will probably
casa long not sure that this helps queen
e seven there is some very c5
yeah I don't know every don't know what
to do complicated stuff at least I want
to irritate them a bit here with long
castles but a for it's not really a
threat
hmm ok but it seems that it this idea
rotated him ok let's see ok if I now
take I need to get Bishop b5 in okay
Queenie seven years play me place maybe
g5 an idea but it's um it's a temple ok
I'll take first if I now go queen is
seven g5 it divot tools well it's not
it's not so bad i mean g 597 i have 95 f
Quint x g5 and a3 hangs so this
provocation on with a five brought some
benefits at least maybe this isn't bad
at all i also have Bishop b5 it came
but that should be a useful move
interesting check gathers should be ok
for black really i mean not nothing
special but it should be a should be a
an ok position so now queen a three days
so i would have looked the eight first
green here that i have this check which
is really really annoying so you must go
somewhere else to d2 air to be too also
osito okay and what now yeah maybe even
Queen edge form what is he doing against
the smooth I don't know let's do it just
threatening to grab pawns
don't know how I did this defend here
now the second time i will just grab
them okay going here 2d aid yeah I have
my own invasion going here only one
minute left that's a bit of a pity
ok let's see the age born
hmm yeah maybe you should go for
something yeah play this but ok um I'm
much really I thought this was rather
quick here may have got I have check on
be one since this isn't something Wow
check 20-something seconds no c 5 maybe
he doesn't have any does not have a
check I'm threatening Quincy one with a
maid time warning
check
check yeah I'm just betting here but the
time
getting again I'm getting this pawn I'm
a not a girl goes to these three of
course 10 seconds Sam huh check check
check check of course rather bland
everything away and went on time she
said I'll play some good moves it's it's
a usual sorry check check check check
Jack forfeits on time yeah jump oh what
you to pledge here was really a bit
strange but it's probably not a win I
mean it really looks like I should ever
made or something but hey there's no
mate there is no made check 23 Jim yeah
i mean it's it's good enough for Joe of
course and check check check I had no
time whatsoever so check okay well he
rather blunt us everything away and
winner wins on time instead of allowing
repetition it's the usual story with
those ancient time controls but it's no
use I have complained to Isis you like
so often and they simply don't don't
react to that so you have to bear with
those somewhat strange results which
don't really reflect the cause of the
game alright thanks for watching